We've seen earlier, how to calculate the average of
an array of doubles to get the average temperature for example.
Now say we want to write some Java code that would
perform basic grade analysis for a grade table like this.
We're given the grades for four different subjects,
for five different students,
which ended up with a table that's
four by five items in it and that's equal to 20 in grades.
We might think, okay we can store all of
those in an array of integers that's 20 integers long.
But this won't help with a lot of the analysis that we want to do.
Like if we wanted to get the average grade for each student,
we'd have to perform this average calculation per student individually.
But if all of these integers were stored in this one array,
it becomes really tricky to match every number in the array
to a specific student in a specific subject.
One solution is to store the grades in multiple arrays.
We could have an array for every student storing the grades for all the four subjects.
And then we could use loops for example,
to calculate the average per student.
But say we wanted to calculate the average per
subject to see how students are performing in Biology for example.
We'd need to access one individual item in
all of these arrays and loops won't be able to help us for that.
Instead, we could possibly create an array for
every subject rather than every student and that way we could easily
calculate the average for every subject individually
but we can't loop over the grades for every student anymore.
That's why when you're trying to deal with data that
looks something like a table or a grid,
Java offers something called a two dimensional array.
You can think of a two dimensional array as an array of arrays.
Like imagine every single row in this table is an array of integers by itself.
We can actually bundle all those together into an array of all these arrays, so that,
each individual array is indexed from zero to three
and then each item inside these arrays are also indexed.
To declare a two dimensional array,
you type in the type of the data that's stored inside,
followed by two sets of square brackets,
and then the array name.
This is because we're actually creating an array of array of integers called grades.
The beauty of 2D arrays is that you can access any item in this table,
given the two indices.
Like, if we wanted to know Tim's grade in biology for example,
we can type in grades of two and one.
This two here is referring to the index of the array that we're interested in,
which is biology in this case,
and the one here in the second square brackets,
is referring to the index of the item inside that array.
Grades of two and one would have 75 stored in it.
If for example, we wanted to know Sam's grade in English,
that would be stored in grades of one and three,
because English has an index of one,
and Sam has an index of three.
We always start with the index of the array itself,
and then the second set of square brackets,
has the index of the item inside that array.
What should we use to find out what Sandra's grade was in Arts?